Speaker 2: Let's go to Aden from the DC area.
Aiden, welcome to the program. What's going on?
Speaker 6: Hey, how you doing? You've
been watching your show for years,
probably since 2017, 2018.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Speaker 6: Just kind of happened upon the
channel today. And notice that you were
alive. I don't really have any particular
question, but, um, I work at a restaurant
in D.C. and I was actually driving around
D.C. on January six. And, and I'll tell you,
it was like when they finally sent people to D.C.
from Maryland, it was the most amount of police
vehicles I've ever seen in my life.
Speaker 2: Oh, interesting.
Speaker 6: But I work with some deniers of
the 2020 election and like even to this day,
like we've talked about it all and they're
just like like they still don't believe
that Biden won. And I guess my question
to you is, at this point, you know what?
What can you do to deprogram people?
Speaker 2: I at this point, I don't know.
We recently looked at a poll where something
like. It was either 40 or 55% of Republicans
still believe that Trump is actually the winner.
It's it's dangerously delusional. And honestly,
I'm sort of at the ready to give up phase where
my thought process is we just need enough voter
turnout to make them irrelevant. And of course,
that's a lot of voter turnout that you need.
But if they still believe it at this point,
what could we possibly show them that would
change their minds? And in fact, I would put it
a different way. They weren't really given any
evidence to get them to start believing this
stuff. So I don't even know that evidence is
what's going to get them out of it.
Speaker 6: Correct? Yeah. I'm kind
of in the same boat. You know, my.
Speaker 2: Problem is there's. There's
so many of them, you know, it's easy to say,
well, just ignore them and get enough votes.
But we're talking about tens of millions of
people here who believe this stuff. You know,
if you say it's for half of the people that voted
Trump, you're talking about 35 ish million people
who believe that the guy who lost actually is
the guy who won. What do you do? What do you
it's you can't fix education quickly. I mean,
these are adults. They're not in the in the
school system anymore to to learn critical
thinking and media literacy. They're I I'm
at a loss quite frankly. I don't know.
Speaker 6: Yeah, I see. I'm a server.
So I come across a lot of people from both
sides. And I've had some pretty aggressive
Trump supporters come in that I've had to serve.
Speaker 2: Really? Like, do they try to
talk politics with you?
Speaker 6: Absolutely.
Speaker 2: How does this how does it come up?
Speaker 6: Well, usually it's it's some jab at
Biden. Know that Brandon guy. You know
I'm with our taxes I excuse my language
but you know something like that and it just
kind of shove it down your throat mentality.
Speaker 1: Wow.
Speaker 2: So and then how do you respond?
Speaker 6: I honestly just try to agree with
them because, you know, like as as lightly as
I can and just avoid the subject because,
you know, serving them, I don't want to.
You know, offend them in any way.
Speaker 2: How do people tip?
Speaker 6: If if they don't think
you're a Democrat, I pretty well, I'd guess.
Speaker 2: Is that you think that that's a factor?
Speaker 6: I do. I actually do.
Speaker 2: Have you had.
Speaker 6: Not with everybody. Just
just I would say more the extremists.
Speaker 2: Have you had situations where a
customer gleaned the fact that you were not
a MAGA guy and that your tip suffered as a result?
Speaker 6: Not that I would directly say like that
it happened, but I've never given it away that
I'm not, you know, for either side. Got he brings
it up. Wow. I try to stay very apolitical.
Speaker 2: Sounds complex, I'll have to say.
Speaker 6: Yeah, I just try to avoid
confrontation. I completely agree. At the same
time, with. With people I work with that I'm more
close to and I care about when when I see that
they believe something that's inherently false
and they're just on the side of crazy. And I'm,
you know, I just can't think of what to
do or say to bring them back to reality.
Speaker 2: Reality. Now, if you figure it out.
Speaker 6: Other than other than I haven't
figured it, other than politics, you know,
everything's great. But when it comes to that,
it's just like they're in a different land.
Speaker 2: I completely agree with you. Aiden,
thank you for the call. I appreciate it.
Speaker 6: Yeah. Keep doing what you do,
David. Take care.
Speaker 2: How many times
have we heard stories like that from servers at
restaurants? It's quite, quite a situation. People
in transportation, Uber drivers, we hear it from
everybody, quite frankly. All right, everybody,
we're going to take a quick break. We will be
back with more Friday show right after this